hello everyone and welcome back to the
champions showdown even though the the
event already ended and we know the
final standings this is one of the games
i wanted to show
uh gary kasparov versus hikaru nakamura
it's a great game and it's
funny because hikaru said that although
he's very happy that gary is in the
tournament
he feels like that uh uh the the games
he played against gary so far are one of
the worst games he played
and the the result is in gary's favor
two of them have played nine games so
far
uh six games in the ultimate blitz
challenge in 2016 and
three games in the saint louis rapid and
blitz tournament in 2017
and uh caspar out of those nine games
kasparov won
two games nakamura won only one and the
six games were drawn so it's uh
the the the score is in gary's favor uh
and nakamura
has an opportunity here to to even it
out so let's see the game uh
it's quite a quite a lovely one so
kasparov opens with f4
uh with d5 by hikaru and now g4 uh so it
makes sense
as uh kasparov rook is already on f1
same as he carves and he wants to
get a lot of activity going he will
later on play the queen to the g file
and he will have very nice support for
these pawns with e6 by hikaru
and knight f3 we have knight to f6
attacking the pawn here and now queen to
g1
yeah like we mentioned now with a very
nice support here
bishop to e7 he cover prepares to shift
the bishop over to d6 to go after the f4
pawn and now d3 because power makes room
for the bishop to defend the pawn
so bishop d6 attacking and bishop d2
defending the pawn
uh knights to c6 hikaru continues
developing
as he will probably castle queen side
otherwise uh he would probably play c5
before playing the knight
knight to c3 kasparov does the same and
now a
not a5 but rather a6
uh taking away the b5 square for the
knight you don't want this bishop to be
harassed in the future
and e5 by kasparov we have capture sun
e4 we have d
captures an e for now threatening to win
material with e5
so bishop to b4 uh now threatening to
capture the knight here remove the
defender of the pawn and just win a pawn
so
kasparov advances it with e5 and now
while you could capture and play knight
to d5 nakamura prefers to keep the
bishop pair so he just goes knight back
to d7
a3 kasparov asks so what do you want to
do capture go back
go back here and nakamura goes back to
e7 with bishop to e2
just continuing development the light
square bishop can be developed to d3 or
to c4 in the future
and now as kasparov spawns are pretty
far advanced here nakamura undermines
them with
f6 uh so e captures on f6 with bishop
captures and
now knight knight to e4 putting pressure
on the bishop
and here nakamura doesn't go back he he
just uh keeps the bishop there and he
forces the trade with bishop to g6 he he
says
okay you can have this one but my light
square bishop will be very strong here
uh kasparov does trade we have captures
captures but not with the knight but
rather with the pawn that
increases pawn presence here in the
center
and both players now castle queen side
and when it's a position like this in
chess 960 always be
you have to be careful because castling
here is a very aggressive move because
when you castle the rook is
already on the d file uh black does the
same
and now bishop to c4 going after this
pawn here there was also the possibility
of going just
knight to d4 with the threat of knight
captures on e6
trying to force force a trade here and
get the queen into the game
but uh that's uh you know completely
different game so bishop the c4 kasparov
goes for the pawn here prepares to
pile up on the e6 pawn with the queen as
he does have very nice control of the e5
square
uh and the queen the g8 defending and
here nakamura will play bishop to f7 as
well to add more protection to the pawn
queen e3 piling up on the pawn and now
bishop to f7 defending and now
queen to c3 putting pressure on this
pawn
okay if the knight moves this is a
vulnerable point but with an even
greater threat of just bishop captures
than a6 if
nakamura captures then the c6 knight
will hang
so knight to c5 nakamura sports this
tactic of course he just
defends his a6 pawn and also has ideas
of playing knight the e4 to attack the
queen and the bishop
uh and here kasparov like if you go for
b4 to try and force
this uh just knight to e4 attacks the
queen the bishop and
here nakamura will just get a lot of
very favorable traits
so after knight c5 kasparov uh could
could play a lot of things in this
position it's a very
rich position like you could play g5 uh
there's also ideas like
maybe even queen e3 to go for for some a
repetition knight d7 queen back to c3
again the same threat knight here queen
queen e3 so that could also be in the
position
it's a very interesting uh uh position
uh but kasparov captures an f6 he grabs
a pawn and says
okay what do you got here uh he says
okay you can capture also my pawn but
then it is just a trade i'm probably
going to play queen g5 over a queen
trade
uh and uh you know just enjoy my
position uh but nakamura says
knight to e4 and now he's pressuring the
queen
uh his queen can always capture the g4
pawn the bishop is being uh
pressured also now the rook is wide open
on the d file
and it's a very very uh tricky idea uh
but there was an even more forcing line
but it's uh it's a really tough one to
calculate and you'd have to waste a lot
of time
the just e5 is incredibly strong opening
up an attack towards the bishop here
and after kasparov trades captures
captures uh now you will have pressure
on the f4 pawn and even if he offers a
queen trade
you're going to block it queen f7 check
kinked
uh rook blocks here uh and now the
problem is that white doesn't have
enough time to capture here because
queen a2
followed by queen a1 is a terrible
threat so here you'd have to waste a
move with king b1 and then e4
uh an incredibly strong pass pawn for
hikaru
so this was also possible uh but okay
after queen captures
hikaru doesn't go for e5 right away he
first prepares it with knight e4
we have queen back to h4 by kasparov and
only now
e5 uh so what do you play here uh
here you should capture and allow uh
allow uh nakamura
to win back a pawn uh but kasparov wants
to keep everything he played bishop to
d3
and now it's actually a winning position
for nakamura but it's a really tricky
move so feel free to pause the video and
win this game for nakamura while i give
you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on paying attention
in the previous line
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show it's bishop the g6
you defend the knight well also
introduce the threat of queen to a2
and queen to a2 is such a big threat
that you simply have to defend against
it
so here kasparov defends with king to b1
but now comes
knight captures on d2 and this is
allowing us part of to
find uh find a proper defense this move
that nakamura played
the true uh strike in the position was
rook captures on d3 but again
in a rapid game you can't find
everything point is that after c
captures you go queen to b3
and now you're uh having so much
pressure in the position
uh everything is just piling down on
white if you if you capture an e4 then
just bishop captures you open up this
diagonal
uh if king a1 just bishop captures an f3
now threatens to win even more material
and the problem is if you move the rook
let's say bishop d5 that's game there's
no defense against this you could
play king b1 to try and make an escape
square but knight here blocks the king
and now this is just game
so rook captures on d3 was the way to go
for nakamura but he goes knight captures
on d2
also incredibly strong but the rule
captures was was
more precise rook captures and now e4
with a double attack so kasparov's next
move is forced he
he needs to play f5 and uh fend off the
uh the bishop the defending the pawn we
have captures on d3
captures on g6 and now d captures on c2
with
check rook captures on c2 and now queen
captures on g6
pinning the rook uh and also uh already
having some very nice threats here you
could play rook captures here
for example rook captures rook
recaptures and then rook to d1
check as the rook is pinned would just
be
easily winning so queen back to e1 by
kasparov uh
he has to keep an eye on the on the back
rank and now queen captures on g4 you
could play
some more active moves here but uh
nakamura says
uh no we're just gonna grab the pawn and
enjoy a much better position
so here rook c to f2 by grabbing the
pawn he allows kasparov to
unpin the rook and now rook to f4
preparing to
uh really grab a lot of a lot of files
here if the rule comes to e4
he will claim this file the d file is
already claimed and
kasparo will have very little room to to
work with so here
king a1 he doesn't want nakamura to
constantly have all of these checks he
has to worry about
so he improves the position of his king
and now rook to e4
as planned queen to c3 by kasparov and
now rook
dita e8 claiming the e file for himself
uh and uh saying uh my position is just
uh
just better so we're just gonna play
that play this out it's no longer
winning uh but it is much better and he
has
way more time than kasparov he has like
uh 10 more minutes on the clock
than gary so rook the c1 uh with
pressure along the c file if nakamura
moves the knight then of course it's
checkmate
so king to b8 uh nakamura also improves
the position of his own king
and here kasparov went for uh queen to
f6
which is weird uh he could play a lot of
things knight to d2 kicks away the rook
rook to f1 also just puts more more
rooks on the f file which is always good
now but he played queen to f6
uh kind of baiting this uh
rook to have to rook to f4 move but it's
uh
it's really tricky because here rook to
f4 is incredibly strong
point is that if this is played with a
double attack here kasparov's
move is probably knight to e5 and here
he probably wanted to trade down into an
end game where he's down a pawn
because after captures captures captures
and captures you're in the same game
being down upon however the rookie 2
move that's
incredibly active for nakamura would
force the passive rook f1
and it's just a very ugly position to
play being upon down
but this was most likely kasparo's idea
behind queen to f6
however nakamura plays rook the c for
instead he puts pressure on the rook
here
uh offers a trade and says uh it's your
move and here
uh best is to either trade or play rook
back to f1 to avoid any rook to f4 ideas
but kasparov played rook to d1 and now
uh
it's a problem now rook to f4 is that
much more dangerous
because the rook is on d1 this allows uh
nakamura to play rook for which he does
and now there's no 95 in the position
because the rook just hangs you pick up
the rook and that's game
you don't have anything to continue with
here so here kasparov needs to go back
or queen to c3 to keep an eye on the
knight here but now nakamura just keeps
piling on
rook e to f8 with a triple attack on the
knight
and here uh rook d rook to d3 defending
the knight once again
uh queen to h5 now keeping an eye on the
on the e5 square also knights the e5
might be an idea to
add another attacker to the knight here
so kasparov finds a very tricky defense
rook the e3 uh he he controls the e5
square now and
allows rook to knight to d4 which now uh
leads to uh uh will uh this knight being
attacked four times uh however
kasparov plays rook to e7 and now he's
threatening rook captures on c7 with
checkmate here on b7 and now nakamura
has to go back he plays knight c6 and
kasparov repeats rook to e3
he he would be very happy with the draw
here if nakamura repeats
kasparov will definitely repeat here but
nakamura finds a different way to
to look for advantage a5 he wants to put
this pawn to a4 and
get the b3 uh outpost for the knight
ready for example knight a5 to b3
delivers check
and will be hard for white to defend so
here kasparov goes to rook d3
there's really not much you can do i
mean you can never move the rook because
the knight falls you can't move the
knight because the rook falls so he
he can just basically repeat moves here
which he does
uh with a4 by nakamura and rook to e3
now we have knight the a5
going for that b3 uh square the queen
nicely uh
cover covers the knight and now knight
the e5 by kasparov he played this
uh hoping for some counter play he's
sacrificing a full rook here
uh hoping that nakamura will capture and
then maybe he can go captures or maybe
there's some knight d7 counterplay for
example captures and then maybe there's
some counterplay here
although not really but you never know
in a rapid game you have to try
something because the position is lost
but nakamura
played the simplest queen to d1 check
and it was in this position on
42 that uh gary kasparov resigned the
game
and a great victory for nakamura which
not only helps him
uh get uh shared first with magnus in
the tournament but
also equalizes his lifetime score
against gary kasparov as now
they both have two victories against
each other so
a very very happy day for for nakamura
uh
probably he will be uh very happy that
he was able to get a win against
kasparov finally
uh in a tournament and not you know uh
be behind against him in a tournament uh
and here you you resign because after
you move the king you just play queen d5
check and now it's a free rook you don't
have any card to play you white will not
be able to capture a knight this square
is covered so no checks are possible and
you can just
after this king moves anywhere you're
going to capture a rook and it's a free
rook white has no
counter play whatsoever for for the
sacrifice rook
so after this queen to d1 check kasparov
resigned and an excellent victory for
nakamura and for those of you who maybe
missed the previous video
do check it out but also here are the
standings after
uh nine rounds so carlson and nakamura
won the tournament with six points tie
uh no armageddon was played as this is
chess 960. so it would be
kind of hard to claim that white has
that big of an advantage without being
able to
actually known theory uh 11 with five
and a half karana with five and a half
then with five wesley so maxine vashila
grav and dominguez with four
uh gary kasparov with three and a half
almost on fifty percent if it
if it wasn't for the mouse slip peter
swiddler with three also a victim of a
great mouse slip
uh and alireza ferruccia in last place
with two and a half points
so uh that's uh the game kasparov versus
nakamura i do hope you enjoyed it and
that you've enjoyed my short coverage of
this
this event i would like to thank
vashishta sri rami apathy evan
patty andrea grossoni and gisen bernard
for contribution to my channel thank you
a lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
uh continuing the next event that we
have coming up in the saint louis
uh uh you know uh tournaments uh
checking up on your wonderful
suggestions
and whatever else happens in the chess
world so thank you all i will see you
soon and have an excellent rest of your
day